Florida Republicans are now looking to
push the state's 15-week abortion ban to
a six-week abortion ban and a few of you
wrote to me and said David this bill
doesn't make any sense women often don't
know that they're pregnant before the
six week Mark but that is exactly why it
makes perfect sense to the people who
are trying to completely ban abortion it
is a feature of this proposal that many
women don't know they're pregnant before
the six-month Mark not a bug and we are
going to discuss that in more detail the
New York New York Times reports Florida
Republicans proposed six-week abortion
ban the bills would tighten the current
15-week limit and offer narrow
exceptions Governor Ron DeSantis said he
welcomed quote pro-life legislation
there is very little that is pro-life
about this bill
if a ban passes write David Chen and
Patricia mizay for the New York Times if
a ban passes and is signed into law by
DeSantis Florida would prohibit abortion
before many women even realize they are
pregnant
the bills had been telegraphed for weeks
Republican leaders who controlled
Tallahassee sought to build on the
anti-abortion momentum generated by the
U.S Supreme Court's overturning of Roe v
Wade DeSantis expected to run for
president said he supports additional
restrictions but the bills offer a
reminder of the political complexities
that he must navigate abortion
restrictions appeal to Republicans but
64 percent of Florida residents believe
abortion should be legal in most or all
cases now that's actually you know this
is a bigger Trend with abortion in
general
which is that if you go back to the
start of the Roe v Wade era you find
that today
rather than a month ago rather than a
year ago today support for abortion
being legal in most cases is higher than
it has been at any time during that Roe
v Wade era and so although the
anti-abortion stuff is useful for
raising money from certain pieces of the
electorate it's useful for playing red
meat games and throwing red meat out to
supporters in practice when you talk to
Americans although there are still many
Americans of course tens of millions who
are just against any abortion at any
time period for the most part Americans
believe abortion should be legal in most
cases and so there is a political
complexity but let's talk about the
six-week thing
um this is the the critical aspect to
this as a de facto way to just ban
abortion completely why well pregnant
women are considered to be four weeks
pregnant by the time they miss their
period often that's the first sign of
pregnancy now another thing that's
important to remember is how closely any
particular woman would be tracking this
does depend on whether she's trying to
be pregnant or not and we'll we'll sort
of get to that but the first day of your
last period is technically day one of
the pregnancy if you have a 28-day cycle
which is sort of like the average so
you're already four weeks pregnant at
the point at which you suspect you might
be missing your period if you're not
actively trying to conceive
you may not realize you're pregnant
within the two weeks that are left after
the missed period and missed periods
can mean nothing right there could be a
plus or minus seven days or something
like that so now you're at five weeks
but the limit is six weeks I know people
who did IVF in vitro fertilization they
were tracking they were monitoring
everything they didn't know they were
pregnant until what would have been five
weeks into the pregnancy most obese
won't even see a patient for a new
pregnancy until the eight week Mark
unless you're having fertility issues
and they say come in we're gonna do
um an HCG I believe it is blood test to
figure out what's going on and check the
level so by this point you are you would
no longer legally be able to get an
abortion in the State of Florida that's
the point and so normal people would say
oh that makes it really difficult to get
an abortion at all that doesn't make
sense the people who want the bill are
saying oh that'll make it really
difficult to get an abortion at all
that's exactly what we want without
outright Banning abortion so this is
something that Florida Republicans are
pushing we're going to continue seeing
this in other states some states have
really old laws that were that are still
in place
but that weren't uh relevant because of
Roe v Wade's existence with the removal
of Roe v Wade now those laws are once
again being
revived and evaluated from a state a
supreme court standpoint in some states
so this is all going to get worse and
worse and worse now quite frankly I
don't think
Republicans at the federal level are
really going to be running on this
because they know the numbers and in
fact
I I may be wrong but in in this nascent
stage of his candidacy I don't think
I've heard Trump talk about abortion
almost ever uh and much of the focus
when it comes to the Social and cultural
issues has been on transgender issues
and we've been talking about that and
covering it so we'll see where this goes
in Florida
we'll zoom out and in a year we will see
where the abortion landscape is but it
is absolutely scary and horrifying stuff